while the president calls for reopening
to be accelerated in some parts of the
country
his health experts are urging several
states to scale things back
our lead national correspondent david
begno joins us now from miami beach
david how was all of this back and forth
affecting businesses there
well take cafeto a restaurant that's
been run by a cuban family for the last
40 years business is down 90 percent
here and they're not sure how they're
going to stay open
a recent report by yelp says that here
in miami-dade county in two
nearby counties almost three thousand
businesses have closed since early march
so with jobs disappearing and some
people set to lose that six hundred
dollar check they've been getting from
the government for the last several
months
there's a lot of tension and you can
understand why
we're seeing a lot of just panic
and people are very scared right now
adrian gonzalez says he doesn't know
what his employees will do
if his restaurant is forced to close
he's already reduced the staff
of 17 to just four and on the west coast
a similar story for marty caballero who
owns a portland barber shop
he says he and many people he knows need
the extra six hundred dollars that
they've been getting from the federal
government
what happens when they shut us down
again there's no extra assistance we're
all getting the minimum
and no one can pay their bills at all
what happens then
the balance of lives and livelihood is
the most difficult thing of all of this
back here in miami beach the mayor dan
gilbert says his city's economy
depends on businesses that draw people
together
restaurants hotels and entertainment
venues and he says the state's contact
tracing program
is not equipped to handle a reopening 83
percent
are not being called at all there's no
contact they're not being told
to quarantine how does the lack of
contact tracing
affect you economically in miami beach
well the contact
tracing is until we have a vaccine the
contact tracing is sort of the vaccine
the ongoing push between public health
and economic concerns
continue as many states see surges in
cases
listen to what dr deborah burks of the
white house coronavirus task force said
we can see what is happening in the
south
moving north there are states that do
need to close their bars
to decrease indoor gatherings to less
than 10.
one of those states is tennis and dr
burks met with the governor bill lee
but he waved off her recommendation i've
said
from the very beginning of this pandemic
that there's nothing off the table i've
also said
we're not going to close the economy
back down and we're not going to
dr anthony fauci is urging states listen
to dr burks
we've got to make sure that other states
that are starting to show an uptick
do what we're talking about before you
get the major surge
you know dr burks also used arizona as
an example that state's governor didn't
want to roll back the reopening but he
decided to
because the cases were surging there and
within the last four weeks dr burks
says arizona has started to turn things
around
because they rolled back their reopening
and she's now using them as an example
for tennessee and other states as to why
they should consider tougher measures
gail boy david i always think it's a
good idea to listen to the scientists
the experts who seem to know what
they're talking about when it comes to
this topic thank you very much david
bagnell reporting
from florida